casimir
tank encore casimir par-ci casimir par
là il n'y a pas de doute je suis
indispensable te fera qu il sans moi
julie je suis là dis moi quel goût mais
olic tu capable de tenir talons tenir ma
langue mais bien sûr regarde bien
attention que ça devrait dire que tu
fais là rachis allait bien enfin tu me
demandes de tenir ma langue je te prouve
que j'appelle le fort c'est court mais
voyons casimir tenir sa langue ça veut
dire garder un secret non la prendra
pleinement un bon alors là tu peux avoir
entière confiance en moi confie mois
qu'on secret dans le creux de l'oreille
que tu n'a pas d'oreille ah bah oui
c'est vrai dans le temps en temps quand
même très bien non tu ça ça ne t'empêche
pas de me dire consacre enfin voila
voila j'ai fait un petit cadeau à
françois monsieur du snob et aux
facteurs pour les vacances mois et alors
alors je voudrais que tu as jusqu'au
port pour m'acheter un beau papier rouge
pour les enveloppes et tu te veut
attraper françois le facteur et monsieur
bus neufs dans du papier rouge la meinau
pain les cadeaux pour que ça fasse joly
tiens voilà l'argent
je savais bien que je n'aurais pas dû
écouter ce secret
mais les acteurs j'ai une idée après
tout le cadeau est pour lui pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils n'iraient pas acheter
lui-même son papier rouge au
facteur est ce que vous avez une minute
à aa mais oui casimir mais l'une pas
davantage parce que je suis en pleine
tournée je ne veux pas prendre du retard
mais ta jolie une minute ce n'est pas dû
à je sais qu'on des facteurs voilà
est-ce que vous seriez tenir vos
oreilles a
évidemment johnny maison et mais quelle
question saugrenue camp ennemi parce que
julie mas m'a confié un secret à et
puisque vous savez tenir vos oreilles je
vais vous confier army now casimir tu te
trompes voilà tu te crois en mon nom
dis pas tenir ses oreilles on dit tenir
sa langue oui c'est avec sa longue que
l'on parle break pas avec les oreilles
d'accord oui ma femme de notre côté oui
si on se tient les oreilles on n'entend
pas le secret donc on ne peut pas
répéter ce que l'on a entendu
ça c'est vrai ça c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais de toute façon il n'est pas
question que j'écoute un secret qui ne
met pas confié à bois quand j'aime bien
c'est comme si j'ouvrais le lettre les
lettres où je dois porter dans enfin
pour six graves et casimir au revoir à
bientôt bon tu sais tenir ses oreilles
en franchement pour pourquoi pas sonné
un à
venir bon bah tant pis
voilà françois et françois françois je
voudrais te parler cemil cicek
importante à quel sujet mais écoutons là
il faut que tu ouvre grand tes oreilles
rien ensuite il faudra que tu que tu
fermes ta bouche promis de revenir tutu
est très mystérieux de costedoat cjt et
bien j millimes à confier un secret elle
ne veut pas que je le répète approuvent
très bien casimir très bien leur surtout
ne le répète pas ce secret
tant pis
peut-être que monsieur du square pour
rameuter
bonjour chers amis à ce bond bram ce
gros casimir la crème des casimir us
c'est du quasi mieux que j'ai parfois
des remords à ton sujet totalement
honnête totalement loyal et puis tu ne
ferais pas de mal à une mouche en hausse
à nous d'autant plus savez vous que pour
pour faire du mal à une mouche il faut
d'abord la crapule et ça ce n'est pas
facile
je suis content vous voir parce que je
vous cherchez est tu me trouves on va
quasiment tous télé pour le mieux dans
la meilleure île du monde oui voilà de
quoi il s'agit julie m'a confié un
secret elle ne veut pas que je le répète
mais je vais vous le dire quand même
quoi oui monsieur le prince en août pour
un autre je crois que je n'ai aucune
éducation oqre ça va venir aucune
moralité et me trompe et bien non il me
dira rien quand je n'écoute rien je ne
vous salue pas
baissé pas haut
je crois qu'il va falloir que j'aille
moi même chercher ce papier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je lui dis gentiment mais
fermement ce que je pensais de sa
conduite je veux tu as bien fait or seul
avis pourquoi est trop sévère avec lui
parce que il est vrai que c'est très
difficile de garder un secret je sais je
lis je sais mon fric ou même le ch est
très mal ce que répéter ce qu'on vous a
confié enfin j'avoue ce qui m'est arrivé
bonjour vous les lignes à casimir a
voulu me répéter est créé que vous lui
aviez confié
fait
concevable et coûteux à eau le facteur
facteurs auriez vous rencontrez casimir
pas à écouter je ne voudrais pas
l'accabler mais il a voulu me confier un
secret
attention je crois qu'il arrive alors
vite cas chez vous dans mon casque je
vais lui donner une bonne leçon d'amour
il la mérite le sac alors tous dans le
privé
julie je suis content de retrouver seul
voilà j'ai des remords j'ai voulu
confier consacré à françois monsieur
sanogo facteurs mais heureusement aucun
n'a voulu m'écouter si bien que personne
ne sait que ce beau papier rouge et pour
envelopper leurs cadeaux
c'est exagéré alors tu tout gâcher
encore une fois mais pourquoi on va bien
parce que monsieur du jetable ça ferait
françois sanchez et que maintenant ils
savent que c'est ce que je leur en fera
un cadeau aux enfants
même sans lui nous aurions été au
courant chers amis en fait c'est vous
qui nous avez dû nous cacher juste à
l'endroit où se trouvaient les cadeaux
en juin
[Musique]